Mark Zuckerberg wants to build the metaverse,
but the crypto community has a different plan.
Now, they might not agree on exactly which crypto
project is best. But one thing is for sure,
they don’t think Zuckerberg stands
a chance against decentralization.
These crypto folks are sick and tired of
having one person exercise absolute control
and they’re funding independent projects
left and right that aim to unseat Zuckerberg.
There’s a problem though. Even though trillions
of dollars have poured into cryptocurrencies,
Zuck and the other big tech companies
aren’t going down without a fight.
Facebook, Apple, Microsoft, and Google are used
by billions of people, and they aren’t just going
to turn over the keys to kingdom to a bunch of
anonymous hackers with pixelated profile pictures.
It’s a knockdown, drag-out fight, and in
order to understand who’s likely to prevail,
we need to investigate 3 important
technological developments.
Crypto will clearly play some
sort of role in the metaverse,
so let’s dig into the battle for payments
between Mark Zuckerberg and the crypto community.
First up, let’s talk about what Facebook has
done in crypto so far. It’s easy to write
off Zuckerberg as a player in the crypto
world, but he’s extremely well connected.
After all, one of his longest standing
board members is Marc Andreessen,
who’s venture capital firm runs a
multi-billion dollar crypto fund.
That fund has invested in crypto exchanges
like CoinBase, NFT marketplaces like OpenSea,
and even new blockchains like Solana.
So Zuckerberg is clearly well aware of
the growing importance of crypto, but a
few years ago he ran into a big problem.
See, it was becoming abundantly clear that
crypto was going to be an important technology
going forward, but Facebook didn’t really
have a way to tap into that world. Billions
of people used Facebook, WhatsApp, and Instagram
to communicate with each other, but when it came
to sending each other money, they usually had to
go use another service, like PayPal or Cash App.
So, Zuckerberg saw an opportunity
to change this. The idea was simple.
He would launch a new cryptocurrency and
then integrate it directly into Facebook.
This new project would be called Libra,
which isn’t quite as catchy as ZuckBucks,
but there was a lot at stake, so I get why
they wanted to use a more professional name.
The first question that came up immediately
was: “why not just use bitcoin?”
Tens of millions of people were already
using Bitcoin, but the network was
too slow for Zuckerberg’s vision.
Bitcoin could only handle around 7
transactions per second, but Libra would
scale to thousands of transactions per second.
Sounds good in theory, but when you’re dealing
with crypto, everything is about trade-offs.
Bitcoin has attracted so many devotees
precisely because there is no need to trust
anyone, you can verify the entire
blockchain yourself if you like.
But this comes at the cost of
efficiency of transactions.
At the opposite end of this spectrum would
be a coin completely controlled by Facebook.
You’d have to trust them completely, but
they could just store all transactions
in a centralized database and
maximize transaction speed.
Now, Zuckerberg and his team realized early
on that this would be a non-starter. People
were having a hard enough time trusting
Facebook with pictures of their cats,
so giving Zuckerberg complete control
over their money would be a stretch.
So the Libra team came up with a compromise. They
would build something that sat halfway between
the fully decentralized Bitcoin blockchain
and a centralized database like Visa. This
distributed ledger structure would allow Libra to
be the best of both worlds, at least in theory.
Instead of Facebook having
total control over the network,
28 separate organizations would work
together to validate transactions.
These validators were all big companies,
like PayPal and Mastercard, and they each
put up $10 million dollars and promised to
provide computing power on an ongoing basis.
This had a big drawback though. Instead
of allowing users to see the entire
history of transactions, Libra would only
expose the current state of the ledger.
This would make it faster, but you’d
have to trust these big companies,
and the crypto community had plenty of
other options. Fans of Bitcoin weren’t
likely to adopt Libra anytime soon, as
long as big companies were involved.
That wasn’t even the biggest issue though.
Plenty of people have no problem trusting large
corporations with their money and data. In fact,
most people don’t even think about it. So telling
people that Libra is semi-decentralized
isn’t that big of a selling point.
See, anytime a new technology comes along, there
are switching costs. People naturally develop
habits and getting them to ditch what they’re
used to in favor of something new is never easy.
When credit cards first came along, they were
basically just competing with cash and checks.
Switching to a credit card meant
that if someone stole your wallet,
you could quickly disable the card and return any
lost funds. That was a huge upgrade from cash,
so people switched over in droves.
But now, credit cards are good enough for most
people. In order for Libra to become massively
successful, it couldn’t just be 10% better
than credit cards, it needed to be 100% better.
So Zuckerberg and the Libra team devised a plan
of attack. Being faster than bitcoin was a good
start, but it wasn’t enough. Volatility had always
been a natural part of all cryptocurrencies, and,
while most day traders loved this
feature, for any average consumer,
it would cause major problems. What if
you go to buy your groceries with Libra
and the value collapses while you’re
standing in the checkout line?
The solution was backing Libra with a basket of
more traditional, and more stable currencies.
The price still might fluctuate, but it
should be a lot more stable than bitcoin.
This created a new problem though, and this would
ultimately lead to the early demise of Libra.
See, the United States government was
already starting to take a hard look
at the platform that Zuckerberg had
built over the last decade. More and
more regulators were arguing that Facebook
had too much control over social media.
If the Libra project worked as planned, that
control would now expand to the financial
sector and could potentially undermine the
monetary sovereignty of the United States.
Zuckerberg knew that he had to tread
lightly here. The spotlight was on him
and ruffling feathers in Washington could
have disastrous consequences. He announced
that he would not launch the currency until
he had full approval from the government,
but the challenge was too much to
overcome, so they shut it down.
Now, while all this craziness was
happening with the Libra project,
the rest of the crypto world was absolutely
exploding. Billions of dollars flowed into
crypto projects and the top developers started
laying some really powerful foundations.
The term “metaverse” wasn’t
even in widespread use yet,
and most crypto devs probably weren’t
even thinking about Mark Zuckerberg,
but these new blockchain technologies would wind
up growing into Zuck’s biggest challenge yet.
It’s important to recognize that the term
“metaverse” doesn’t just refer to a single
game or VR experience. We’re talking about
the next phase of the internet yet. Just
like mobile phones wound up evolving everyday
activities and creating entire opportunities,
the metaverse is basically just a catchall
term for the next phase of the internet.
In fact, the term “metaverse” has
been so completely co-opted by Zuck
that a large portion of the crypto
community has moved to calling this
whole idea “Web3”. But regardless
of what term we use to describe it,
clearly payments are going to play an
important role in the future of technology.
This can be hard to see sometimes though.
Especially when cartoons are selling for
millions of dollars and Elon is tweeting
about dog money. There is a ton of noise
in the crypto space, as well plenty
of scams, so be careful out there.
And quickly, I’ll never ask you to message
a random phone number in the comments,
but you can subscribe to the channel.
Now, once we separate out all the junk and get
to the core of this technology, how can crypto
actually help build the metaverse? Well, the
first area is interoperability. Right now,
that basically just means bringing a digital asset
from one game to another. Which might seem silly,
but remember, the virtual economy already
generates over $50 billion dollars per year.
But honestly, who cares if you can bring
a Minecraft skin into Call of Duty? Does
that really create any meaningful value or
advance technology even the slightest bit?
As silly as this all sounds, I actually do think
it’s an important step forward. Here’s why.
Right now, every traditional tech company
is building its own little walled garden.
Epic Games makes Fortnite. You buy a skin
in Fortnite, it lives in Fortnite forever.
Now Epic Games could allow digital
assets from other games to transfer
into Fortnite. They might need to build some
complex pipelines to port the assets over,
or define an open standard, but they could do
it. The only reason they don’t is that it would
hurt their business. Epic wants to be the only
company that can sell dancing bananas in Fortnite.
But, if crypto can break down these walled
gardens, the playing field will get a lot
more competitive. Creators building
any small piece of the metaverse will
be able to ensure that what they build
continues to make them money forever.
If you can accept the fact that the $50 billion
dollar virtual economy is basically “real” at this
point, it becomes a lot clearer why crypto might
prove useful here. A virtual asset might be bought
in one game, and then sold in another. Making
sure the creator gets a small royalty payment
would be incredibly complex without crypto,
but NFTs make this both simple and reliable.
This allows developers and creators to
stop worrying about building an entirely
new walled garden, but instead focus on
making useful building blocks. One person
builds some virtual land, then another develops
virtual houses, and yes, then someone probably
makes a dancing banana. Actually, the dancing
banana probably comes first. Let’s be honest.
Now, to be clear, we are clearly
still years from all of this coming
together into anything resembling the
Metaverse that Zuck is talking about.
Most of these projects are still in
their infancy and only a few have
built significant user bases, but the
building blocks are starting to form.
The immense wealth created by the
crypto boom over the past decade
really can’t be discounted. Bitcoin alone
has minted dozens of new billionaires,
and most of those folks aren’t about to put
their newfound wealth in traditional tech stocks.
They are investing in the next generation
of crypto projects and helping build
infrastructure for what they see
as the future of the internet.
Obviously Zuckerberg isn’t the only person the
crypto crowd is up against though. Tons of people
passionately hate crypto and want NFTs to fail,
but most of their criticisms are pretty flawed.
You’ll commonly hear people say that NFTs are
bad because of their environmental impact,
but there are already alternative blockchains
that use less energy per transaction than
a single Google search. You’ll also
hear people point out that NFTs are
just links to files stored on centralized
servers, and that’s true for many projects,
but not all. Some projects do in fact store all
of the data related to the NFT on the blockchain.
But technical arguments aside, by far the biggest
critique you’ll hear is around prices. The
anti-crypto crowd will jump at the opportunity to
point out that we’re in a bubble and prices can’t
possibly stay this high. Just look at what
happened during the dot com boom and bust.
And that’s a good point, we should look
at what happened during the dot com boom,
because I actually think history could tell us
a lot about what the future will look like here.
No one denies that the year 2000 was
a crazy time for technology investing.
Companies were going public
burning millions of dollars,
all while providing very little real value
to everyday people. There was a vague idea
that this technology might be useful one day, but
few of the business models made any real sense.
Then, the market crashed. People lost stock
portfolios, lots of people lost their jobs.
But there was a silver lining to all this
market mayhem. During the dot com bubble,
investors had financed huge infrastructure
projects focused on laying fiber optic cable
in the ground. Actually connecting every computer
to the internet was an incredibly costly endeavor,
but without these connections,
there would be no internet industry.
So the investors ponied up millions of dollars
and got the fiber into the ground. After the
dot com crash, it looked like a waste. All
those high-flying tech companies that were
planning on using this new fiber were now
bankrupt, so were these cables now useless?
Well, not quite. With the infrastructure now
available, people started building again, and
pretty quickly. On October 9th, 2002, the NASDAQ
hit a new low, down 78% from its peak. Just over
one year later, a young Mark Zuckerberg would hit
publish on the first version of thefacebook.com.
So how does this relate to crypto? Well,
even if we are in a bubble, it’s possible
that the foundational technologies that are
being built today will prove incredibly
useful to a future batch of companies.
And it can be useful to go back even
further in time, to the turn of the century.
The pace of technological progress was really
staggering during the industrial revolution.
Engineers had partnered with financers like never
before and were taking on increasingly ambitious
projects. Westinghouse and Edison were duking it
out to build the best system for electrification.
Henry Ford was building the first automobile. And
the Wright Brothers were inventing the airplane.
The telegraph industry created a boom of capital
and engineering talent in search of the
next big thing. Lots of people failed,
but some people landed on some
absolutely groundbreaking territory.
So most crypto supporters are hoping
for something similar to unfold here.
The money is clearly already there, and lots of
smart engineers have moved over to building crypto
projects. That puts Zuckerberg in a tricky
position. If one of these projects breaks
out and becomes essential to the metaverse,
he could be stuck fighting on his back foot.
But in order to understand
exactly how this might play out,
we need to dive into the history of one of
the fastest growing blockchains in the world.
Tons of metaverse projects are already being built
on top of it, so watch this video to find out why.